[Music]
you ready all
right it's the it's not my fault someone
made this the perfect height yeah I did
that so that you would do that you can
just lay down and put the put the
instrument between your
legs oh yeah that's true you know what I
mean there he
goes damn I just got a shot of the the
beer
belly oh you got a little mid drift then
I saw I saw some mid drift yeah talk
about a stomach
blessing yeah he's in there uh did you
hear about this new McDonald's
restaurant yeah Cosmic what is it well
you know what's the point of it cosmics
they want their own Starbucks bro is
that what it is they want to own some
Baristas as well
H yeah so it's most no but they have
food items
though but it is it's very drinks
focused yeah and I think I think it's
also uh competing with like Dutch Bros
and [__] like that yep doesn't it
looks like Sonic too you said that churo
frab see they're already working on you
what's the cows on that bad boy 500 this
is worth every
calorie and if you and in case you were
wondering you can get a fountain drink
as well so if you wanted Coca-Cola with
your coffee and your Island pickme up
punch you can get all three in the same
place
cosmix people are like this has been
everywhere and I looked into it because
I was like oh they must be opening these
everywhere it's like one location yeah
in like Ohio or something so why the
[__] is this
news um cuz McDonald's paid for it to be
news yeah
true true nothing's real yeah nothing is
real also it's so funny how they can
just drop these down in the maybe I
shouldn't say this what I mean whatever
it's so funny how McDonald's puts this
[__] everywhere in places where they can
just kill people yeah the first Cosmic
open to the public on Thursday it's open
it's sorry it's in boiling Brook
Illinois like cuz if any Suburban person
dies there it doesn't
matter I see what you're saying speaking
of which dude the [__] charged
lemonade yeah [__] is so funny yeah how
people are dying from it yeah yeah crazy
how
I don't yeah you'd think like Celsius
would have a bajillion lawsuits right
yeah people die from that [__] all the
time yeah well you would also think that
when your heart is just jamming hard as
hell from the lemonade you might want to
go cuz anxiety or like caffeine anxiety
I guess maybe it's people that don't
feel
it wait so that's how much caffeine it
has oh so it's like not even close to a
[__] why are there people rating it
like it they're like it's four cups of
coffee in one sip so how do people die
from this it's people with pre-existing
conditions the first girl who died had a
heart condition and didn't know that
there was this much caffeine in it oh
yeah right cuz it's just lemonade yeah
like why would there be caffeine and
lemonade that that is a massive context
okay so the person who died was just
drinking the lemonade thinking it was
lemonade cuz they had laugh at a Fiat
driver man I
know I meant charged the concept of
charged lemonade is very funny and the
tweets have been funny about
it bro that's all I mean I don't mean
the person that died from it is funny
that's actually horrible cuz the old
person would just walk in and go I like
lemonade yeah can I get a lemonade
they're they're like I feel really F
right now [__] yeah I feel like I could
run oh [__] yeah that's not
cool one cup is right under the max
amount per day
[Laughter]
the max amount of caffeine so a bang is
like double yeah what's a
Celsius no no no the the Panera thing is
is more than a bang yeah it's more it's
at the upper end oh wait what was that
the one that was per ounce but this has
way more ounces than a bang does oh oh
so it really is like jacked the [__] up
oh yeah like why would they put that
much okay it's clear now it is clear it
wasn't clearly labeled that it had this
much caffeine in it and it was self
served you could go get a refill just at
the counter yeah self Ser why would you
self that's what I mean old person walks
up pre-existing condition I like
lemonade drinks two of these things 40
100 milligrams of
caffeine he got two refills and died on
the way home two refills
mhm so he had 1,200 milligrams of
caffeine something like that he must
have felt charged the [__] up yeah like
I said he probably felt like he could
build a
spaceship damn that's sad as
[__]
yeah I mean but
also so Ryan just walked on set and
pretended to throw a watermelon at
Cody
my life flashed before my eyes dude this
a morbid episode what this is a morbid
episode the doubt the yeah that would
have been my Fiat that would have been a
great ending if you if you got killed by
a watermelon yeah seriously yeah dude
who would die from [__]
[Laughter]
lemon8 Don this has been a morbid
episode the [__] cave
guy charge lemonade I'm somehow get for
this going be like Noel in his dark
humor
yeah
um yeah yeah this has been a morbid but
hey was you know life is morbid
sometimes I guess damn I'm scarred from
that I could see that thing coming at my
[__]
[Music]
head oh
[__] oh [__]
[__] I really [__] goofed this time
[__] [__] oh
man I be
dude yeah so they knew he was in there
yeah how did they
know did he have a little like emergency
thing maybe
yeah I think he just guys
yeah I'm stuck look look look just how
do you do that
alone it's insane I mean you're asking
for this to happen you have to know in
the back of your head like something
like this is going to happen one day
yeah yeah even if you're not alone like
how the [__] would someone get him out
of there out of 137 people who tried to
rescue him only a few could even squeeze
down
there yeah
bro that's even worse that you hear
people trying behind you and they can't
get you out oh my
God